I'm Ben I'm Amanda I'm Jan I'm Chris
annihilating ghosts I have no real
reason for actually believing in ghosts
I was raised Roman Catholic so maybe
it's a religious thing I believe that
that ghosts could be out there I haven't
seen them personally but I have
definitely not counted them out of the
realm of possibility I watched a lot of
horror movies and was really gung-ho on
ghosts and spirit life I'm friends with
a lot of like spiritual people they told
me that I have an affinity for spirits
and I'm hoping that that means that I
won't get possessed yes I have no idea
what to expect tonight the closer we get
to actually having to go there the more
like I can feel my nerves getting a
little cranked up what I'm hoping will
happen is that there will probably be
ghosts that try to communicate with us
but I don't think it's gonna be like
violent like in horror movies the worst
thing that could happen tonight is
someone getting possessed
I am immediately regretting everything
this seems like a stupid idea
my name is Chad I'm co-founder of a
Medela paranormal um I'm Josh I'm the
founder this is an asylum I had found
before it's been kind of locally known
there's no actual evidence of this being
an asylum it's all folklore there's no
actual address to this place there's no
real roads here literally in the middle
of nowhere a couple things that we've
gotten here we've got a lot of voices me
and Daniel actually heard a little boy
laughing we've got EMF hits here
confirming that there is some spirit
that either believes there nurse or was
once a nurse let's go ahead and get this
started you guys everything off is there
anybody here with us tonight you've seen
this earlier we have a smaller group
they actually believe in you can you
feel it it's all cold
so what it does is you'll hear this
noise and it will cycle through radio
stations we're on the moodle mill where
there's no radio stations out here it's
going to be blank if you hear our voice
our enemy come through most likely it's
paranormal is there anybody here tonight
so that wasn't us
are you speaking to a further back
building
are you allowed to come over here to
this building
are you guys okay yeah it is kind of
eerie
it could be just like I said keep your
eyes open everywhere and when you're
ready everybody go ahead and go dark
yeah I hear something too behind you
yeah it sounds like it just sounds like
crack like crackling that's separate
from that
nobody answers oh are you still here
with us
what something ran across out there how
we're out in the distance like between
from this like where this building is
back there ghost sunny was exhilarating
I thought it was a lot of fun I was
disappointed not much happened as I
expected it to but I still felt like
there was something there through the
course of night I like I felt like I
went and faced this fear that was
probably rooted in a lot of irrational
like imaginary thinking I was terrified
the entire time I came out of it very
nauseous actually I still believe that
supernatural things can occur out there
I definitely still think that ghosts
exist that Paranormal Activity exists
places are haunted I still believe that
there are things that we can't see that
interact with us and like there are
people that say that they want real
concrete evidence for it but that's not
how the spiritual world is supposed to
work it's because you didn't see
anything doesn't mean that there wasn't
anything there I ain't afraid of no good
I know been keep your ears open
sometimes I feel like a slight touch of
breath to just meters as I run I feel
like they're feeling breaths and touches
it's just so sad what's happening over
there oh yeah you don't know the half
you